see grapes let's sail which leans on
light tired of islands a schooner
beating of the Caribbean for whom could
be Odysseus home bound on the Aegean
that father and husbands longing under
non sour grapes is Magne adulterer
hearing now saccas name in every girl's
outcry this brings nobody peace the
ancient war between obsession and
responsibility will never finish and has
been the same for the sea Wondra or the
one on shore now a wriggling on his
sandals to walk home since Troy aside
its last frame and the blind giants
Boulder heave the trough from whose
groundswell the great hexameters come to
the conclusions of exhausted serve the
classics can console but not enough